my name is Solomon Giorgio that is my
real name it's a very beautiful name for
a very beautiful man my last name
Giorgio is Italian
I am Ethiopian some people wonder how
does an African get a European last name
well it's a lot like a fairy tale except
in this fairy tale there happens to be
an Italian Army occupation of brutal
civil war a few decades of famine and no
happy endings but my first name
well my first name Solomon is actually a
very old biblical name is given to me by
my uncle Mufasa I got Tony so sure that
you guys know that I am openly gay well
most of the time just took a break from
Martin Luther King Day yeah sometimes
just want to be black and nothing else
you know I also I work at a fine dining
restaurant because I'm a well-spoken
ethnic homosexual very hot trend these
days you know and it's a little painful
for me because I am an immigrant from a
third-world country and I have to deal
with foodie people call themselves
foodies all the time and God does not
strike them dead on the spot
I original had this woman's snap at me
and when I came up to her she goes
excuse me do you have any Himalayan sea
salt took all my restraint not to lean
into and go my mother once had to eat
her cat when she was 9
[Laughter]
of course we have Himalayan sea salt are
you kidding me go so well with Ethiopian
cat I recently watched the Disney
Animated Feature Pocahontas because I'm
a grown man and no one can stop me from
doing whatever I want however I feel
that movie should come with a written
apology firstly the Native Americans as
a people have suffered the worst
genocide in human history some may say
hey Solomon what about the Holocaust and
I wouldn't take that away from anyone
the Holocaust was a terrible terrible
tragedy however I have seen 10 or more
Jewish people in the same room
I haven't seen tentative Americans in my
life
we used to live right her secondly
Pocahontas was a real person in this
nation's history
she looked nothing like the Disney
character because she was hella busy
being 12 she was sold to John Smith and
his men suffered years of sexual assault
witnessed the death of most of her tribe
and then shipped off to England to die
young death due to smallpox now someone
at the Disney Corporation caught wind of
this tale
and they thought hey how do we make this
family-friendly I got it
get rid of power why people look bad cuz
that is just gross then we'll throw in
some singing some dancing and her dude
I apologize the only impersonation I can
do is a blacker voice for what other
movies do they have this one is about a
young african princess named sally who
falls in love with a young man named
thomas jefferson stay onboard they get
married and she helps him write the
Declaration of Independence huh
with help from a friend Roscoe the
singing fried chicken Tom the dancin
watermelon name the movie zero years a
slave
you